parce qu'il ya comme un problème à
régler avec le désir de l'homme ce
qu'ils oublient tout qu'est comme normal
tout le temps qui comme ça où ces chiens
et à moi on fera ça dégage c'est un peu
naïve c'est un peu bête c'est un peu
tout ce qu'on veut mais bien sur scène
que la une la colère mais tout ce que
vous racontez ici c'est à dire ce monde
de de l'esbrouffe ce monde de la chanson
du rock se montrent des boîtes à part
tout ce monde du sexe c'est un monde que
vous connaissez bien
bah oui forcément c'est un monde
d'hommes je suis dans un monde d'hommes
quel est le rôle des femmes doit mettre
profil quoi donc les rôles des femmes en
gros cette fois les pythons je suis
dedans quel est le rôle des femmes dans
ce monde de l'amuser amusé mais j'aime
musée et puis peut-être que prendra le
pouvoir quelque part on verra plus tard
et on moi je veux le pouvoir maintenant
quoi en tant que femme il faut aussi en
tant que personne qui est pas né dans
les beaux quartiers chauds le pardon je
vais de mixité de pouvoir maintenant
sexuelle et sociale
je voudrais un truc maintenant
maintenant parce que je mets mon sexe
entre terreur tout de suite c'est un
truc qui est dangereux tout de suite
c'est vrai le moment dans le lit vous
raconter une femme qui est vêtu d'une
manière assez provocante mais se balade
dans le quartier de barbès
la sérénade pal se promène pas encore là
parce pavani n'est rien juste que ça
fait comme une fille et bah oui hélas se
promener à barbès et c'est une folie
furieuse et faut essayer de le faire
pour comprendre à quel point c'est vrai
quoi c'est vrai c'est ridicule face et
c'est grotesque voilà céréales quoi pour
le faire mais vous êtes bien en femme
qui allait s est ce que vous ne risquez
pas dans ce livre quand même une
détestation du désir de l'homme ouais
moi j'ai des contacts d'échappement
c'est normal je pense pas je m'approche
des rideaux à top alors moi c'est toute
ma vie je suis là dedans je pense ce
sera un peu prometic mais que j'en passe
par là j'entends oui le problème parce
que ce désir de l'homme il est beau il
il est permanent peut-être mais il est
aussi insolent aussi arrogant aussi
ouais mais je crois que c'est elle il
faudrait qu'on habille le jeune garçon
de 16 ans filles qu'on les envoie dans
la rue est un petit peu quand je pense
qu'il comprendra peut-être un peu mieux
de quoi je parle
me réserve par contre j'ai pas rêver je
rêve pas quand on joue
la russe est unique et et combien on
sera pas belle c'est pas une question
d'être belle aux poubelles c'est une
question est tangible
une fois qu'on est en jupe
[Musique]